i
ah
en colombia el papel de los indígenas es
clave en un país en el que el 58 5% del
territorio es bosque más del 48%
pertenece a los pueblos originarios
precisamente en esas tierras en las que
las responsabilidades de los indígenas
la deforestación es dos veces menor
datos the world wide fund dicen que el
impacto de los indígenas ayuda a la
conservación del 80% de la biodiversidad
del planeta mientras que sus bosques
proveen un tercio de la solución al
cambio climático sin embargo su papel de
defensores medioambientales también les
sitúa en un grave peligro en colombia'
de 102 pueblos indígenas según la
comisión de la verdad encargada de
esclarecer el conflicto colombiano 68
están en riesgo por ejemplo desde la
firma de los acuerdos de paz en 2016
entre el estado colombiano y la
guerrilla de las farc y hasta mediados
de 2020 doscientos cuarenta y dos
líderes indígenas fueron asesinados es
la cifra del país más peligroso del
mundo para los defensores de la tierra
quienes tratan de proteger sus
territorios de las economías ilícitas un
compromiso que les ha valido que la onu
les declara de los mejores guardianes de
los bosques
[Música]
en perú los pueblos originarios son los
principales aliados no solo en la
defensa y conservación del medio
ambiente sino también en la lucha contra
la deforestación ellos han estado
trabajando durante la pandemia del cob y
19 y precisamente por proteger a la
naturaleza en los últimos meses 7
indígenas fueron asesinados por encarar
a la minería ilegal al narcotráfico la
tala ilegal y la deforestación que
invade a sus territorios ancestrales
depredando bosques y la biodiversidad
diversos colectivos reclaman al actual
gobierno ya los candidatos
presidenciales una protección integral a
los defensores del medio ambiente
mientras tanto algunas comunidades de la
región san martín en la amazonía
convierten a la tecnología en su mejor
arma de batalla con teléfonos celulares
y drones armaron una plataforma integral
que les permite monitorear más de
670.000 hectáreas de bosques y así
afrontar los desafíos para proteger la
biodiversidad las fuentes de agua y las
áreas verdes
[Música]
en ecuador de mountain en quisimos una
de las principales activistas indígenas
waoranis que lucha por proteger los
derechos de la amazonía los árboles y el
agua es un sagrado para los pueblos
indígenas considerados los mayores
guardianes de bosques en américa latina
y el caribe según la más reciente
informe de las naciones unidas el aporte
indígena evitó que 59 millones de
toneladas métricas de co2 se produjeran
en el mundo equivalente a sacar de
circulación a 12 millones de vehículos
en un año por ello insiste en que sus
territorios se convierten en zonas
productivas y se detenga la explotación
petrolera en ecuador propone en las
selvas vivientes para declarar los
territorios zonas protegidas en el país
andino existen 200 buques protectores
que significan más de 2 millones de
hectáreas que representa el 9 por ciento
del territorio nacional los bosques
protectores intervienen en la protección
del agua los suelos la flora y fauna
[Música]